all right problem 42.
so say for the system of equations given
this is the system of equations they
give they say
x
minus
is equal to z
they say y minus x is equal to 8
and that 8 minus z is equal to t 8 minus
z
is equal to
t
so they say for the system of equation
what is the value of z so we're trying
to figure out z and then statement
number one
they tell us
that x is equal to seven
x is equal to seven well if we know x is
equal to seven we can solve for z right
here because x is 7 then 7 minus 4 is z
so then that
so 7 minus 4 is 3. so z is equal to 3.
that was pretty straightforward so 1
alone is sufficient just using this
first equation in the system
so let's see if 2 is of any use
t is equal to five
t is equal to five well this is easy one
two you put t is equal to five right
here
and then you could easily solve for z
right you get eight minus z is equal to
5 and you can solve for but i'm not
going to do it you just have to know
that you can
so this alone is sufficient as well so
the answer is d each statement alone is
sufficient
problem 43
is x equal to five
is x
equal to five
and statement number one they say
x is
greater than or equal to 5 well that
doesn't tell me whether x is equal to 5
it just says it's greater than 5.
statement number 2 tells us x is less
than or equal to 5. once again that does
not tell me whether
x is 5 but if i told you that both of
these are true x is greater than or
equal to 5
and
not or and x is
less than or equal to 5.
well actually
that's still
well the only the only the only x that
satisfies that equation that satisfies
both of these
is 5 right i mean you put 3 in 3 will
not satisfy this one if you put 7 in
seven will not satisfy this one so the
only thing that satisfies it is
is both this is five sorry my brain's
malfunction a little bit so you need
both of these so the answer is both
statements together are sufficient
c that one's confusing because it's so
simple on some level
44. the table above shows the dis let me
see if i can draw this table
oh
didn't they write
really right there right r
s
t
u
and r
s
t
and u
have a bunch of things let me just i
don't know what these are yet i haven't
read the question but let's see
y
x
0 69
and then
62 that's a six
69 and zero
and what are they going to ask they're
saying the table bus shows the distance
in kilometers by the most direct route
between any two of the four cities for
example the distance between city r
between city r
and city u is 62 or if you said between
u and r it's going to be 62 as well
right that's the same thing fair enough
what is the value of x
so the value of x is the distance
between t and r let me circle that
they want to know what the value of x is
the difference the distance between t
and r
so it's that one and another way to look
at the distance between t and r that's
this one so these are both x
fair enough
okay so statement number one tells us by
the most direct route the distance
between s and t
so we could say the distance between s
and t i'll just see this line segment s
t
is equal to twice the distance between s
and r is equal to 2 times
2 times
s r
so let's see do we know what s r is
sr is equal to
y
right and st
st is equal to 56. we figured that
so st is 56 let me do this
st is 56. do you mean s and t is 56 so
is equal to 2 times s r
the distribution s and r is y or s and r
is y so it equals 2y
and so we can solve for y y is equal to
28.
and we actually didn't have to solve it
but let's see i'm just trying to see
where this goes
but that still doesn't help me
figure out
the distance between
what did we have between r and t that
just helps me solve for y y is 28
y is 28. statement number two
see where this is going
by the most direct route the distance
between t and u
so the distance between t and u
is 1.5 times
the distance between r and t
r and t so the distance between r and t
this is the interesting thing because
this is our
r and t is is is x right so they're
saying the distance between t and u
is equal to 1.5 times x and what's the
distance between t and u
the distance between t and u is 69
right between t and u is 69. so you have
1.5 x is equal to 69 you only have to
solve it you just know that you can
easily solve for x if you know statement
number two so statement number two alone
helps you figure out what x is statement
number one is fairly useless so the
answer is
b statement two alone is sufficient
draw a line here i don't wanna
okay problem number 45.
45 what is the value of the two-digit
integer x
so 2
dig
integer
x equals who knows all right
statement number one
the sum of the two digits is three so
let's say that x is equal to the number
a
b where this is the tens digit and this
is the ones digit so statement number
one says the sum of the two digits is
three so
a plus b
is equal to three
well that doesn't help us there's a lot
of
well you know that these are going to be
positive numbers
but we don't know whether they're two
different numbers
two
x is divisible by
three
x is divisible by three well i don't
know if you learned that trick in in
school but any number that's divisible
by three the sum of their the sum of
their digits add up to the sum of their
digits are also divisible by three so
once again that just means that a plus b
is equal to
some some multiple
of three well if you keep adding them
they eventually add up if you had a two
digit number so this is a c
let's see just a plus b is equal to
three
this could be a couple of different
things you could be see a two digit
number
i mean it could be
three zero
three zero it could be 1
it could be 12 it could be 21.
i think those are all of the the
possibilities that we can have just off
of statement number 1.
and x is divisible by 3 all of these are
divisible by 3. so really both
statements give you no information so
the answer is e that both statements
combined still give me nothing
but all of these are possibilities
and actually this one leads to many many
more possibilities that x is divisible
by three because then you could have
things like i don't know
this would have been a valid
a valid number as well so this would
actually give a lot more this is a
little bit more restrictive but anyway
either way we can't figure out what x is
it could be 30 it could be 12 could be
21 could be anything
all right problem 46.
what is the tenths digit in the decimal
representation of a certain number so
the tenths that's the number right
behind the decimal point so the number
let's just call it x so statement number
one says x
is less than one third
and two
says that
x is greater than one fourth
so this enough to figure out what the
tenths digit is
so what's a number that's less than
one-third let me just think of a couple
of them well one-third is like .333
repeating so if i just write point
three
two
that satisfies one
and it satisfies two right point three
two is greater than one fourth
but what's another and and then in this
case a tenth digit would be a three well
let me try to find another one that
would satisfy these both well let's see
greater than one-fourth what about 0.26
0.26 is definitely greater than
one-fourth and it's definitely less than
one-third
but both of these have different tens
ones as a two one has a three there so
even both statements combined still do
not allow me to solve the problem
there's not enough information given so
once again e together i'm still not
getting enough information
oh i'm almost at 10 minutes anyway i'll
see you in the next video